Oh Jeffrey look look yeah I mean it's
already disrespectful you don't have to
add to it I'm Jeff I'm destiny hi my
name is Sean I'm a proud cheapskate
my name is Jojo and I want to say I'm
kind of a big spender
and today we're gonna be comparing our
spending habits oh don't say that's what
it is
I don't know I feel like for everyone
food it's just a big one I I don't eat
out as much as other people right now I
would say I mean cuz I see him around
all the time so I'll say clothes
he's oh oh he's always addressed my
career thank you thank you this is
actually for my mother's closet okay if
I had to guess I know all of Jeff's
money goes to food for a fact I didn't
know don't be like that first off and if
it does go to food it's macaroni cheese
that's not the point
mmm got to be close it got to be close
whether it's online or in the store
gotta be close I was texting to the
other day she's I was like where you at
the mall I didn't need to ask her where
she was at mmm destiny on all of them
yeah I mean there's just no way like
what I buy and vision are don't really
see price tags so money bags over here
is for sure destiny yeah I think that I
spend the most on every category there
could be um I'm also going to say don't
suffer it's good I'm that confident and
how frugal I am I I wear it like a like
a trophy look that's me all I'm saying
is when I do eat out there's green stuff
on there I swear
Jeffrey look look
it's already disrespectful you don't
have to add to it Jeffrey look right
Jeffrey this is disrespectful look if
you come from me I'm coming
I use the one yeah but I have two things
all of these have three digits except
travel you were offended when I said you
probably spent at least on clothing
where is woody where what what what yes
on travel three hundred and fifty
dollars on clothing
show me the Gucci belt because I feel
like you have it Jordans cost a lot okay
okay that's fair that's right that's
right why me a dog kind of wrong here so
free eating out 50 $60 I know that's my
actual total for the last month it's
when you sit I'm about to just really
drag you honestly honestly if we're
gonna be real about it full transparency
there was a lot of like dates and there
like I was like oh we're gonna get
drinks $70 can I share the nothing no
you don't got okay can I sure
proceed if you're uncomfortable I won't
share it no I mean it's life this is for
a month
listen and I'm also trashed so drag us
both but Jeffery spent seven hundred and
thirty dollars on eating out in one
month see what happened was you spend
$650 on cosmetics okay seeing this hair
by itself was almost by five hundred a
little over five hundred you know Dana
the product that I use that's talking
nothing like thirty forty well on the
other hand this cost me a $25 yeah I'm
looking at my hair yeah that's actually
probably my biggest expense no what
happened was I died down at overtime I
didn't see a couple friends this month
so I had to see what's up like all let's
go grab dinner let's go to our blood 701
just thirty days you must been having
multiple meals a day yes I eat breakfast
lunch and dinner so there was you don't
make any of that this is no no no this
isn't oh I had Starbucks for breakfast
I had chick-fil-a for luncheon and up
for dinner this is we have steak and
lobster all three meals every day of
this month sometimes when you want to
take out a nice lady you like we got a
wine and dine running and dining you
don't get that for $50 you know you guys
spend a couple dollars
look listen I'm not trying to be no
average guy on the street okay
I'm one and the dollar but hopefully not
like that because I really can't afford
that that's that oh he's paying $5 yeah
that's all you need you know friends are
free you know if you have nice friends
sometimes okay for you but you don't
always have to spend money to fun with
your friends you know oh no you live you
got thirty dollars for clothing Michaels
every month like that thank you very
much I don't I'm good on my clothing
toiletries I also started to get on as a
woman makeup ladies you know makeup can
last for months it's not something you
have to buy every glass come out you
spend thirty dollars on clothes but
somehow you got $200 worth of
transportation where are you going
I don't have to put out all your
everybody to tell you where you live
that okay mine was this was a very busy
time so I was going to different events
and like you know me I'd like to be on
the scene and if you're gonna have a
drink or two you should not be driving I
miss influencer I forgot a little of
cosmetics is 128 toiletries ten dollars
priorities here toilet paper highly I
really don't like honestly speaking Ivan
properly updated my wardrobe if it's
high school I think so I mean I'll buy
like one or two items during like a
holiday sale but that's literally twice
a year a hell of a lot better about my
trash spending see my own budget makes
me want to cry I don't need to see
someone else's
budget most definitely I think this just
kind of confirms that I'm on the right
path I don't say that I feel like I
don't know I guess the regular adult I
might still be kind of childish our I
still think I need to cut back like this
is like too much but seeing his budget I
feel so much better about myself I feel
rich now I'm like well I'm about to go
post make me a meal after this like no
see my but it's it horrible don't need
don't mean bad it's good that's like if
you can do it you can swing it I did
speak I thought money banks over here
was spending more than me I don't know
where this is coming from say no to
everything like just say no also eat
before you go out but if you're not
gonna be drinking drive somewhere or
this is something I've done before if
I'm not drinking I'll make sure to drive
somewhere close to where I'm going and
then catch a three-dollar ride chair to
the location but park for free somewhere
look at your bank statements more than
once a year so you can actually
understand because a month isn't that
long but it is when you're swiping your
card five times a day yeah things I
learned don't eat out guys if you go if
you're trying to splurge kind of go out
go get drinks on the first day you ain't
got to get dinner take the spot I'm not
saying that's all my money's at thank
you I'm saying that was a thing or
something else I've done that you I
think some advice for you Jeffery pack a
lunch she used my whole name you know it
was serious Jeffery pack a lunch hmm
Monday through Friday or Monday through
Thursday Friday Saturday treat yourself
you know what it means to pack a lunch
all right
first off how many times gonna have
chicken steak or pork chops first of all
you're packing a lunch long make a
sandwich
ohayo debit card just know your
priorities know what you need to spend
money on and what you want to spend
money on not everything in life is a
necessity keep a keep a ledger write
down all of your expenses and then at
the end of each month take time to
reflect on what you spent on and going
forward strategize how you plan on
tackling the next month and at the end
of each year show your fiscal calendar
show the expenses show your liabilities
I was also an accounting major in
college so it's okay I can help you too
[Music]